welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the first trailer for the flash
released during dc fandom teasing the
upcoming flashpoint event confirmed to
cross over barry allen into alternate
timelines that include michael keaton
batman from the tim burton films as well
as ben affleck returning as his version
of batman and ezra miller playing
multiple variants of himself
looks like dc is reclaiming its timeline
crossover from marvel who's trying to
beat them to the punch with their own
franchise callback parade and spider-man
no way home hey i'm here for both of
them just to keep michael keaton as
confused as possible as to what
franchise he's in are you peter or barry
i'm will and i'll be adam warlock but
this is dope sick on hulu after i
reacted to this flash trailer i have
since discovered even more details that
helped explain this flashpoint movie's
convoluted plot how barry from the dc
films ended up in a shared universe with
keaton batman essentially to explain to
michael keaton if you are watching the
exact nature of this multiplicity copy
of a copy logic with the multiple barry
allens and let's actually start there
with the two barry allen's in the final
shot or at least two characters played
by ezra miller the first one in the
center has shorter hair and wears the
new tech infused suit that we've seen in
other shots in this trailer and then the
one on the left has longer hair and if
you look closely is actually wearing a
bat suit from the michael keaton era
that's been customized with the bat
emblem spray painted over with the
flash's yellow bolt logo there's another
shot that shows them doing the same with
the keaton era bat suits boots both of
these berries are arriving at wayne
manor in a taxi from central city now we
know this is the wayne manor from the
keaton films with the same exact
architecture and gate and gothic statues
out front and then the iconic batman
cowl from the caton era steps up in the
bat cave with computer terminals and
metal railings and circuit breakers all
matching those in the batcave from
batman 1989 and batman returns 1992.
however we should know that the batcave
in those films did not have a waterfall
the waterfall was added by christopher
nolan for his dark knight trilogy but
the cobwebs and covering sheets may
imply a passage of time in which bruce
wayne may have made some structural
changes like blowing out a cave wall to
give him easier water access or this
could be yet another variant universe
from the original keaton burton timeline
but either way what is going on in this
movie well this flash movie is adapting
the 2011 flashpoint paradox event from
the dc comics in which barry allen uses
a cosmic treadmill to go back in time to
stop the murder of his mother nora allen
which his father henry allen was falsely
convicted of and we learned that the
murder was actually committed by future
time traveler eubard fun aka reverse
flash who snuck back through time using
his own kind of speed force based on
negative emotions in order to try to
kill barry allen as a child but ended up
killing nora allen instead all of this
timeline meddling causes barry to cross
over into the flashpoint timeline which
is kind of a post-apocalyptic world
where batman is not bruce wayne bruce
wayne was killed in this timeline
setting up his father thomas wayne to
become batman the flashpoint paradox
storyline ends up getting resolved with
dc moving forward with the new 52 series
but the dc films have been implying they
may be headed in a similar direction
just in need of one big crossover
storyline to establish the rules of the
dc multiverse in its various else worlds
like in the justice league snyder cut
barry visited henry and vowed to prove
his innocence but henry warned in some
new dialogue i can't sit here
and watch you running place in central
city for some old dude
yeah run in place a nod perhaps to the
cosmic treadmill zack snyder also added
dialogue and scenes directly tying
barry's speed force to time travel i
might be able to jump started i don't
like to break this rule but when i
approach the speed of light i look crazy
things happen to time barry ends up
reversing time to sync the motherbox
with his jolt and doing this triggered
cyborg's dark premonition showing dark
side conquering earth killing wonder
woman and aquaman joker's implied
bombing of the bat cave killing lois
lane that turned superman against the
justice league and setting up that whole
nightmare epilogue to the snyder cut the
future that barry allen in batman v
superman was trying to warn bruce wayne
about now zack snyder has suggested that
his nightmare epilogue was really set in
a separate microverse than the ongoing
dceu but now in this flashpoint story
it's probably gonna be one of many
elseworld timelines that barry could be
crossing in and out of just like we saw
him do in a cw grant gustin barry allen
crisis of infinite earth's event now yes
i obviously consume a lot of content and
help me get through it all i like to
snack i'm kind of an expert on pairing
snacks with content phase one mcu go for
chicken fingers and tater tots dig into
some whatever loki gummy bears and
twizzlers all day but when it comes to
pairing wine with food i'm much less
confident in my picks for advice on
which wine to drink with which food i
lean on our friends at brightsellers and
thanks to brightsellers for sponsoring
this video brightsellers uses a quiz to
determine your taste preferences and
then they show you a list of the top six
wines that you're most likely to enjoy
from around the world and if you like
your recommendations and you want to try
them they'll ship them straight to your
door they educate you about wine along
the way with their wine education cards
that have useful info like tasty notes
and pairing recommendations a wine
from bread salads so normally i'm a red
guy but i want to go for a white and
they sent me a meat cute which does not
have a meat flavor but it's got stone
fruits like peaches nectarines and
apricots with soft perfume florals like
honeysuckle in the aroma i like all
those flavors i can't wait to give this
one a shot i've received a bunch of
boxes from bright sellers over the past
year based on my feedback they always
adjust the wines they send me and
brightsellers is giving our followers 50
off their six bottle box and the first
100 people to check out will get a free
corkscrew so follow that link and take
the quiz to get started so i think now
after his graduation in justice league
but before the dark side apocalypse
would ever begin barry's work with the
central city crime lab will unearth
evidence about nora's murder that barry
will now need to reverse time to go back
to that night to fix but interestingly
in this trailer we see two versions of
barry returning to that house a
nighttime shot of barry in his
futuristic new suit and then a morning
shot of barry in casual wear finding
nora in the kitchen one theory is that
this second shot is our barry from the
main timeline finding his mother alive
and instead the nighttime shot may
actually be reverse flash the night he
kills nora meaning since miller is
wearing this same suit in the final shot
that miller could also be playing
reverse flash in this movie reverse
flash in the comics does undergo surgery
at one point to look more like barry
allen and then all these shots in wayne
manor could be reverse flash crossing
over into the keaton burton timeline on
a recruiting mission putting together a
team to stop our original barry from
fixing his past and that long-haired
berry on the left could be the berry
from that keaton burton timeline aware
of the batman as a gotham legend long
after bruce wayne was outed and retired
becoming a recluse and so they go to his
estate to try to use wayne's gear to
give this barry a new suit and then run
into bruce wayne and are able to trick
the old man into joining the team
alongside sasha kaye playing this
timeline supergirl all to stop our
original barry who in another timeline
is working with his original ben affleck
batman so that would kind of give us two
teams team one dceu ezra miller flash
plus ben affleck batman versus ezra
miller as eobard vaughn reverse flash
plus keaton burton timeline barry allen
and that timeline supergirl as well as
michael keaton batman that could be why
we hear michael keaton's voice asking in
this trailer tell me something you can
go
anywhere you want right any timeline any
universe why do you want to stay and
fight to save this one yeah this batman
would be rightly asking what this guy is
doing here in this universe and the
question is valid because reverse flash
is actually here on deceitful pretenses
but of course we could be overthinking
it and it's often the case here in the
rockstars this night time shot and
morning shot may be the same berry the
night he prevented the death he actually
does see a lamp turn on suggesting
someone else is inside there and the
next morning after he saved nora the
futuristic suit may just be a new suit
that he designed after the events of
justice league like there's a close-up
of his ring which barry uses to store
his suit that spreads out to its
form-fitting shape around his body and
there's also a shot of the longer-haired
berry covering iris west barry in this
shot wears that ring so it's possible
that both of these berries are the flash
from their respective timelines and the
reason our barry came to the keaton
burton timeline to answer bruce's
question from the teaser is that this
may yet be the timeline that eobard fun
originated from and by saving this
timeline and giving keaton batman a new
purpose they're trying to prevent thon
from ever becoming a time traveling
threat to our barry allen and his family
but ultimately i think two takeaways are
true after seeing this teaser one that
the keaton burton timeline while
important will not be the only alternate
dc timeline this movie exists in and we
may yet see the flashpoint thomas wayne
batman timeline i mean we gotta have
something for future trailers right and
two one of the ezra millers we see in
this movie may very well be playing
reverse flash eobard thon only because
most of the other main cast in this film
has already been announced and no heavy
hitter yet confirmed for reverse flash
and while i still think homelander actor
anthony starr would be perfect for this
role i just think it's easier for warner
to keep it under wraps by having miller
double up in the role hey if you like
what we do here at new rockstars be sure
to subscribe for breakdowns of
everything that you love and support us
by checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
me rockstars and social media and thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you